hemos estado hablando de curvatura y
bueno por ejemplo tú tienes una curva
parametrizado por una función vector
valuada s dt y la curvatura te mide que
tanto se curva esta curva aquí por
ejemplo se está curvando bastante por lo
tanto la curvatura es grande pero aquí
se curva poco porque hay poca curva es
decir está casi recto aquí está casi
recto en el vídeo anterior vimos esta
fórmula algo complicada y para recordar
te decía que la curvatura denotada por
capa mayúscula se calcula como la
derivada de la función del vector
unitario tangente piensa en una función
que te dé vectores unitarios tangentes
en cada punto de la curva son vectores
con longitud de 1 y son tangentes a la
curva esa función que buscas será una
función del mismo parámetro tenemos la t
mayúscula para denotar al vector
unitario tangente y la t minúscula para
denotar el parámetro entonces tomamos la
derivada d
con respecto a la longitud de arco s
no con respecto al parámetro t sino con
respecto a la longitud de arco s y la
longitud de arco se refiere a tomar un
pedazo pequeño de la curva digamos que
tenga medida de s
y bueno te preguntarás cuánto cambia la
dirección en ese vector unitario
tangente para que esto quede más claro
puedes imaginar lo siguiente imagina que
en otro espacio vas a colocar a los
vectores unitarios tangentes anclados al
origen todos tienen la misma medida
miden 1
entonces en lugar de poner los tangentes
sobre la curva los pones en un espacio
distinto todos anclados al origen y
todos miden lo mismo la derivada es
decir el cambio en ese vector tangente
será otro vector que te indica cómo te
vas moviendo de un vector a otro es
decir cuál es el ángulo el ángulo de
giro con respecto a cada vector entonces
la curvatura no está dada por el vector
porque entonces esto sería un vector
está dada por la norma y en el vídeo
pasado vimos que cuando vemos a esto
como una función vector evaluada con
componentes x de t dt resulta ser igual
a esta fórmula
esta fórmula complicada que ves aquí
veamos como esta fórmula si nos dice que
tanta es la curvatura en cada punto de
la curva primero observemos el numerador
tenemos x prima de t que es la primera
derivada del primer componente
multiplicada por jerry prima
qué es la segunda derivada de la segunda
componente menos puedes notar que aquí
hay simetría tenemos que prima de t
multiplicada por xvii prima de t
tal vez esto te recuerde al producto
cruz
si tomamos si tomamos x prima y priman
funciones de t
como un vector
y hacemos el producto cruz con el vector
que contenga las dobles primas entonces
tenemos aquí xvii prima de t
y lleve prima de té si tomamos el
producto cruce entre esto ahora si no
recuerdas el producto cruz también hay
vídeos sobre eso puedes verlos un
producto cruz se calcula de la siguiente
manera tomas las componentes de la
diagonal y las multiplicas entonces
obtienes x prima de be prima y después
le restas lo que está en la otra
diagonal puedes ver que se parece más o
menos a determinante así que tienes x
prima yeví prima menos xvii prima jet
prima así que bueno voy a escribir esto
en términos de nuestra función es el
primer vector es la primera derivada de
s tenemos entonces s prima de t y la
estamos haciendo producto cruz con s bi
prima de t
pero bueno qué significan estos dos
vectores es decir cómo interpretamos a
la s prima y a la sb prima voy a dibujar
aquí una curva la función s nos está
dando vectores cuyas puntas trazan esta
curva
mientras te varía
y ese prima de té nos dice cómo deben
irse moviendo las puntas de los vectores
para que vayan trazando la curva
mientras vas de un vector a otro es
decir nos dice cómo debe irse moviendo
cada vector lo cual quiere decir que el
vector en cada punto dado y viéndolo en
cambios muy pequeños siempre obtienes un
vector tangente todos estos son vectores
tangentes no necesariamente unitarios
tal vez tengas un vector tangente muy
largo indicando que estás viajando por
la curva a una velocidad muy alta por
ese espacio y ahora el vector con la
segunda derivada s prima de t puedes
pensar en todos los vectores tangentes
en un espacio distinto si si esto
representa ese dt s prima de t se
observaría así este primer vector grande
se ve algo así indicando que va a una
velocidad muy
muy grande muy rápida luego un vector se
observaría así y éste iría apuntando
hacia abajo y puedes ver el cambio en
todos estos vectores que representan la
derivada y observa que todos inician en
el mismo punto podemos suponer que ese
mismo punto es el origen porque al
iniciar en el origen nos da información
de cómo es el cambio entre cada vector
entonces en particular veamos el cambio
de este vector a este vector la punta
debe moverse en esta dirección entonces
está segunda derivada nos dirá cómo la
punta del vector resultante de la
primera derivada debe moverse
similarmente para cada vector nos dice
cómo debe moverse esa punta del vector
en qué dirección ahora cómo ejemplo si
tomamos una curva muy cerrada vamos a
tomar una curva muy cerrada como esta
tendrás un vector tangente en dirección
un tanto a la derecha
rápidamente la dirección cambia a la
derecha hacia abajo
así si yo dibujo estos vectores aparte
iniciando en el mismo punto
si los dibujo así puedes ver como el
vector de la segunda derivada le dice
que gire en esta dirección y si estudias
qué pasa a nivel infinitesimal avanzando
de un vector a otro obtienes este
movimiento de giro para los vectores
entonces el vector de la segunda
derivada estará jalando de manera
perpendicular a este primer vector
derivado indicándole que gire en esta
dirección
ahora dibujando eso si tú tienes un
valor con la primera derivada y el
vector de la segunda derivada es
perpendicular a él este vector de la
segunda derivada le indica al vector de
la primera derivada en qué dirección
debe girar el vector de la primera
derivada ahora si suponemos que no fuera
perpendicular pero también se mueve
hacia abajo esto le estaría diciendo al
vector de la
primera derivada que de alguna manera se
encoja indicándole que está girando y
haciéndose pequeño lo cual quiere decir
que la velocidad de la trayectoria de
ese está disminuyendo y si el caso fuera
que está girando pero a la vez está
apuntando como simulando que se aleja
así eso querrá decir que el vector de la
primera derivada va a crecer entonces
girará y acelerará en la curva pero
nosotros queremos medir qué tan
perpendiculares son estos vectores el de
la primera y segunda derivada porque ahí
es en donde entra el concepto de
producto cruz porque la interpretación
del producto cruz es básicamente el área
que obtienes al tomar estos dos vectores
y formar con ellos el paralelogramo que
así se traza el producto cruz al darle
el área te indica que tan
perpendicularmente están posicionados
estos vectores el uno del otro porque
bueno supongamos que apuntan en una
dirección muy parecida es
quiere decir que el paralelogramo que
trazan estos vectores tendrá un área muy
pequeña comparada con el paralelogramo
que trazan estos dos vectores que son
perpendiculares o casi perpendiculares
pero bueno en el siguiente vídeo
continuaremos con esto